[Music]
in take a break news submitted by you
deserve a vacation oh thank you me
everyone thinks it deserve a vacation
even if they just have noticed that
sometimes I need a vacation from my
vacation because I went through a hectic
vacation like we walked so much it was
so awesome
I need a relaxing vacation now yeah
Kasey's vacation is coming back home
from the vacation vacation I second that
companies in Japan may implement musical
drones to force workers to go home and
rest Wow oh damn [ __ ] Japan is crazy they
always come up with these different
tactics to get people to stop working
gholem and be a [ __ ] human being how
about stop giving people more work than
dumbass the reason why people are
staying so long is because they can't
finish their work
give them realistic [ __ ] goals and
realistic you know get deadlines that's
why people are over working now you
shrink their [ __ ] work hours so they
can't finish their deadlines it's like
you're just putting more pressure on
them yeah like that there's an idea room
and it's like hey boss what if you took
less pressure off the employee I never
mind that sounds stupid no but they need
to take their breaks though but the
musical drone though right yeah some new
technology okay yeah like what like what
like hey boss what an idea I mean what's
the music to it a musical drone that
what like plays the Darth Vader theme
like wave that Scottish song the auld
lang sin oh that one near the bagpipes
we play
one of the world's most sung songs
around the world
apparently there's a back pipe set and
this is supposed to make me want to go
home oh the New Year's thought I knew
your song yeah you don't mean this kind
of has the the closing this is the
somewhere it's like it's time to go they
should play closing time yeah yeah yeah
so the best song in Japan they play that
when they're closing the stores this
song really that's dope cuz you know
when it closed the bars they always play
journey really oh because they make
everybody sing and then they walk out
the bar and then they forgot yeah I like
how they just turn on the lights on
drunk people yeah yeah it really works
like it never works until then that's
true and then you see how busted
everyone Oh everyone looks [ __ ] numb
people are getting warm embrace me oh
yeah god you're like your own wife
you're like oh my god crazy cuz that
lighting is just nuts yeah when it's hot
I mean when it's dark everyone's like
goddamn that looks good it look good
baby uh-huh even you everyone suddenly
has cellulite on their face that's
called dimples bro oh and melty makeup
yeah well we have the multi made
everyone except for Julia suite Julia
thank you you don't cellulite on your
face oh wait never mind I see it now I
got two of them so this drone here that
they're trying to implement into the
working space it's called T friend and
pretty much what they're saying is that
this will buzz over late working
employees and then start playing that
song or this play
could let them know that it's time for
them to go home look like that song
sounds so calming I feel like I would
probably fall asleep it's this dark in
the ah wait go to bed closer that dark
in the office you're alone working at
the computer everyone else went home and
all of a sudden is like it's worse
you turn around in the [ __ ] flying
robots behind you forget it
like that's so scary that is pretty
scary this is if they're saying like
this would be that kind of sort of the
plan wait so what's happening to these
people at work when they don't go people
in Japan that are dying from overworking
and that's becoming like a problem and
companies don't want people to overwork
and die I've heard a lot of your board
committing suicide because of the amount
of work that their Jesus I've heard
about guys who play World of Warcraft
too long at like internet cafes in Japan
and they died there of starvation yeah
the game that's just all over Asia they
like to just game their life away and
then they die do their starvation or
they just eat really poorly or yeah it's
not enough nutrition for them to that's
crazy man keep their body alive this
doesn't really have an official price
tag yet but they're talking about maybe
having it cost about four thousand five
hundred dollars per month just to send
people home just to send people home
this is the amount of money that they
would be paying for this drone you just
have an intercom system I yell go home
turn off the [ __ ] power the
developers are thinking about adding
facial recognition technology so they
could penalize the ones that are always
staying late or identify possible
intruders oh that's great no security
but you know what's crazy I used to work
for this Japanese company and they would
say like over there let's say you get
like 10 days vacation right but most
people will only come back and paint no
one wants to take the full ten days it's
all about like how you look or something
like saving face yeah something like
that where you don't wanna be the guy
taking advantage of the company right
right wait you're like you want to be
the guy that's like I only needed eight
I didn't need ten it's cool so everyone
just does the a thing so I'm like dude
that's so [ __ ] confusing they give
you ten but you
and everyone else takes eight and in so
who's the who's the guy that that has to
be the problem and it goes I'll take
seven say oh [ __ ] man thanks thanks a
lot Satoshi you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I just wanted work more like you [ __ ]
man I wanted eight days yes I saw a guy
diet my office ml job oh my god he just
collapsed and died he just fell just
just had a heart attack yeah yeah he had
a heart attack collapsed and then like
his blood was like in a pool on the car
because he hit the desk on his way down
why are you smiling
well that's as I say to you privately
[Music]
when you guys are talking on bed with
your legs kicked up like that with their
[ __ ] feet up you know how comfortable
that [ __ ] is you real date the dating
game or whatever with the phone and it's
like it's like you're on the phone with
your girlfriends or something your best
girlfriends and then like you hit a
button and like Brad's like I really
like you I'll talk yeah girl talk yeah
that was it you know take a board game
teaches girls like to really make guys
love them because that's all that
matters in life yeah is that guy's
giving affection that's it no no so yeah
so then his blood was on the carpet for
like five like three or four months
because the [ __ ] the employer guy was so
cheap he didn't want to change the car
picture and you saw this yeah you just
collapsed in the little office from
everybody yeah who's crazy that is crazy
he died he like died and so like you
could tell he was probably dead because
all the blood was like was everyone like
whole [ __ ] and didn't think they walked
away or they were creamy like mostly
people were just like like really shaken
by it like really in shock I think and
then everyone's like yo get the [ __ ]
home no yeah yeah cuz a weird
dick maybe no he was a really nice guy
all the good ones have to go Oh anyone
cry at least not a single person no but
it would because it was it was [ __ ]
sad dude because we found out afterward
that he had no family like there was
nobody to like claim him but he had
[ __ ] nobody dude he had the job and
that's it what job was this this is what
I used to sell printer toner yeah you
worked at like a place that don't blur
mifflin like that yeah like that yeah
yeah we did printer toner dude we we was
like that you know and we used to supply
printer toner and all the printers for
like Lockheed Martin Northrop Grumman
like and [ __ ] even a couple NASA
building that's like the most typical
905 thing that Yuki like anyone can do
like I was a job it's like working for a
company that sells like calculator parts
yeah yeah that's the most corporate
office ii thing that can do oh yeah I'm
surprised more people didn't kill them
smells frankly was it really boring it
was really bad yeah really boring and
they it was like you weren't when I when
I was leaving like to go because my
youtube stuff was doing okay and it was
time for I could leave the job I
remember writing a company-wide email
and everybody being like it was like
really nice working with all of you
underneath these fluorescent lights with
these gray walls you said that oh yeah I
finally got to say it and then I was
like it was great sort of nodding at you
in the morning while we all walked by
silently in fear like yeah cuz the
bosses were hard-ass like those the main
boss guy was a hard-ass like did not
want people [ __ ] around and I like
[ __ ] work for a Japanese company yeah he
was I think he's a Korean guy oh just as
scary just as scary that was before I
was with dinky so I couldn't tell the
difference now I kind of get it yeah she
helped you out with the Asian most
Mexican looking Asian I sure did that's
the only way I'll take them
[Music]